citizens of the reject Nation me terar Ericson
Gregory thought he was going to talk and I'm
like no just settle down cuz you know what Greg
he's sick but he's got some stuff going on okay
and I have to shoot a film it's a sag low budget
okay it's an indie film so I'm not against the
strike because me love SAG we got to roll through
this this is the only time we can do it so we're
rocking we're rolling yeah man yeah good you did
it you put the disclaimer out there we appreciate
it I did also guys we're doing this despicable
thing you guys have all said Despicable three
that's what we're going to watch is like maybe
not the good one so is minions good we'll see
we'll see though minion we need to know right
us juice should we do the Minions we're going
to should we do the Minions give us the juice
should we do it listen give us a juice send us
a like a comment type in there that you love so
much also ring the bell ring the bell also if
you're a super sexy reack which means you're a
patron you get to watch the full reaction sink
up with your own copy like it's a watch long
with me and Greg and you like one big happy
family so if you're not a patron get on top of
it John and Greg cover several shows exclusively
over there with highlights and watch alongs
included so you know you get to see more of
Greg and John which I'm like I'm also here but
like it's fine you can get over there and watch
a lot of them I think that's it also thanks
to prepper for editing this video we need to
get into it let's watch Dispicable Me Before
Greg throws up and before I have to be on set
[Music] whoa this says is PG for
nudity and violence nudity weird
and foul language Guru is like look
at my minion oh wow yeah that's not
the reaction no I I really no
one wants to see his minion
illuminat illuminat
that fart gun has really milked it I'm half
hoping that we think this is the best one yeah
me too and we try to prove everybody else wrong
1985 and the number one show on TV was evil brat
evil brat cool alas are brats as a child prodigy
and criminal mastermind honestly this looks like
a show I'd watch I know right but it all came
to an end in season 3 when I've been a bad oh
no puberty yikes tough actually believe he was
the character he played on TV I've met these
people God where is he now he's still running
the streets of LA in his purple tracksuit oh
no's on boat he's the villain playing a villain
on TV was fun but being one in real life life
is even better Heist music here it comes what is
that voice actor of him or the robot the actual
guy cool still wearing purple
all the time I like it nice moves
whoa oh my God that's so dumb
there's no way there's no
way H oh clever oh all right blow up bubblegum
is this guy like the dancing villain like he's
going to dance every time he does some
villainous stuff hey I'm okay with it
don't be cynical that'd be awesome I'm okay
with it I want every agent in the area on the
seed immediately Finding Nemo oh no the little
fishy agents gruy are closing fast yes wait
what gruy grw and Lucy mush together try it I
like it but not a lot I don't like [Laughter]
it this one's a 3D cuz I'm
bad I'm bad you know it wow
this guy really rebounded after being a failing
actor right
now it's it's kind Co wearing a stranger thing
shirt today considering is an 80s guy wow he's
getting the way that's what he thinks oh all right
so hot Lucy all right I don't think we can make
it through we can make it we can make it uh no
how would you have grabbed onto them yeah like
there's nowhere to grab on to oh sweet sauce nice
good thinking Lucy that's great transition how you
doing are you okay love that overconfidence
you should be on TV that's right you
are kick his ass
gr no he's going to he's going to out dance him
you know I go for the hips wa it's at the Middle
Point wow that bald spot is blinding Beggars
can't be choosers ter did you actually think I
was unconscious it's called acting hoser and
clearly I've still got it I like this guy's
gadgetry sweet kear nudity yeah I've been a bad
boy son of a BX the the animation just
keeps improving though this isn't
over grw I still have the diamond
[Music] oh like they just landed on the
beach and then became like top DJs I love
that for them and they can pull off
anything oh damn into the E into the
three again how is this possible
how Trey Parker from South Park oh oh okay it's
not even worth talking about I don't even want
to was that's not so secret man I feel like
you would get caught all the time doing that
yeah you're like plainly going into the sky in
a couch on a couch it is with great sadness I am
retiring as head of the AVL no I loved you darn it
don't you remember him such big character left an
impression yeah head office effective immediately
oh wow all right long legs blonde hair whoa Ambi
what is going here oh I mean someone finds her
attractive which one of you losers is ancient
grou that would be me how could you let Bazar
brat just get away that is the opposite of what
we do here you did didn't get the diamond and I am
this close to bringing him in interesting you're
fired fired R is a great agent you know what
if you fire him you're going to have to fire
me sister sister no we asking for it they're
asking for it by showing up out of uniform
they're literally the only ones with normal
clothes on everyone else had a suit disrespect
it was coming is he going to have to go back to
being a villain M I would like that but then he
has to fight the okay he's got to out fill in
the dancer he's got to learn dance moves I've
decided hello well this one looks
the best so far waa that looks cool
yeah cool how cute you never got to go on
honeymoon so we made your dinner it's aout
oh my God so cute that's what everyone wants
in their honeymoon for their children to be
there I love them the gummy bears were my idea
oh yummy a good old Gummy Bear soup looks too
good to even eat but I made it for you you have to
eat it you better eat it g yeah you better she's
so adorable I love the combination love gummy be
meat so how was work oh did you take that guy down
did anything explode well actually they're careers
Lucy and I were invited to not work invited to not
work they're the best part of this oh
my God you could gamble online that's
Katie's dad does that's a good suggestion
and let's not go over to Katie's house
anymore I know it's been a little tough lately
especially with Dr nefario accidentally freezing
himself in carbonite what a dude poor guy they
could not a very good scientist couldn't get
Russell Brand to commit to being on set
[Music] go dark let's for lunch be bad
we're not going back to villain and I
don't want to hear another word about
it ciao Bell you're serious come on
yeah stop on that hat oh boy you're
in charge now h i mean if he just gets
that one guy he'd be able to get his job
back right but he doesn't have any dance
skills and purple tracksuit guys got a
lot they keep getting bigger I know they make a
lot of fat jokes in this the chief of police sent
me he was concerned that during the recent Hast
attempt the Dumont Diamond was replaced you could
hear him jiggling you have been deep what by me oh
it's fake he's the guy he is an actor oh [Music]
no oh okay oh no oh oh got
it huh I've been a bad boy or should I
say I mean he seems like a really competent
villain though yeah like a difficult one to
take down like it's like all really easy for him
a true Anarchist I'm waiting for this movie to
get terrible yeah me too and so far I'm like this
is about on part with what I know for Despicable
Me yeah I feel like lost a failure a like I
don't have a purpose anymore welcome to my
weekly crisis it's daily for me well that makes
sense looking at you you should feel like with
her EXC me pardon me people
there's a lot more texture
in this animation like darkness
and shadows like yeah it's more
striking I didn't know that the dog's name
was Kyle until just now helps you if you
have Nightmare and he's really good to snuggle
with Agnes Agnes no not the big fluffy unicorn
she giving away her stuff no sweet girl I just
wanted to help since you don't have a job she
is the best character in this whole franchise she
really is I would never sell anything to help out
her get off the lawn yeah but hey could you of
course no as I was saying I uh oh goodbye uh the
villain is coming oh my god wow just murder that
guy he just killed that guy I feel like they also
killed that guy in that car earlier too oh good
he's not dead my name is CH and I am inquiring on
behalf of your twin brother Drew he needs your
help Drew what your father has recently passed
away I'm sorry but my dad died when I was a baby
huh how do you explain this you oh MRE what did
you do oh my God he's so much more successful
holy to Molly oh there's a mom just lounging
around never mind it's important to keep active
in one's Golden Years wow mommy oh my goodness I
have a twin brother how did you find out it's true
didn't even try to lie that was the agreement what
are you talking about oh she gets one he gets the
other your father and I divorced we each took one
son to raise on our own and promised never to see
each other again interesting to throw a divorce
element into a kid movie I don't really hear that
too often yeah Alo that's sad I have a brother I
don't think I would care if you had a twin brother
yeah you would you'd be like let me just get a
look at him we don't need to have a relationship
but like you really look like me or what does he
do reactions CU of what does he do hi piggy piggy
whoa look at that house oh my god well if my twin
brother live like that I want to go meet him
what's with all the pigs this is the family
business the largest pig farm in the whole of are
you doing here they're into making bacon oh who
this is amazing that looks pretty awesome uh what
have you done I mean I'm down my [Music] brother
Dre oh no oh my God he's even got a full
head of hair wow you must be the beautiful
wife beautiful oh oh she would totally go
for him oh yeah you're this you're small
with big eyes and it makes me want to put
you in my pocket you can't do that I'm too
big and Margo oh you are so mature I'm guessing
why you 15 15 she's 12 she looks 12 and will
always be 12 yeah creepy place is amazing sure
I'm not really into things oh my gosh why are
they not pink they're all red is he laundering
drugs through those pigs ooh a little cocaine
all right let's go home now home why I don't
know this guy with the mansion and the cars and
all the hair he's jealous you could kill him and
take his identity yeah you girl should go with FL
bye you boys have [Music] fun you know people
clown on 1% centers all the time as terrible
people but it' be nice to be like a five for
Center or something you know a five forent
and the all new Mega Diamond laser oh wow this
guy's got his own toys and stuff evil brat was
a masterpiece it's a disgrace and a travesty sir
this time I'm cancelling you and all the losers
who rejected me oh no we live there wow not
good to watch while there's a strike going on
true is it broken [Music]
oh oh how cool would that be what is all
this the pig farm looks like Harry Potter
Chambers his
laugh what very creative set in layers and
he's a criminal yeah no no no not just a
villain but one of the greatest super super
super villain the bald Terror more like bald
D I feel like he never went full bald to
D I was just a failure never thought I had
what it took to be a villain wow interesting
ju the position they're drawing here teach
me the art of villainy no I left that life
behind me end the story I wonder what this
does oh is he going to hold them as
collateral this holy moly dad's villain
Wheels oh so this one's combining the
super villainy and the super spy stuff yeah
all into one big mumbo jumbo What a Beautiful
Day Z to 43 seconds able to withand a
nuclear blast I'm to the te whoa It's a
hybrid he said it's a hybrid [Music]
Oh I thought they were going to
go in the water and swim around a
bit I mean the animation of visuals are still very
cool pretty it's pretty cool I like the
point of view of the camera too yeah the
way they lock off the shots are really
awesome I am not enjoying [Applause]
this who the Drew guy is a little annoying
though yeah absolutely 100% welcome to the
annual fredonian cheese festival go what that
where how do I go to there that seems insanely
dangerous can we get these please okay but
only one each a no I don't you want I don't
care it's okay to tell them no sometimes
too you know not when you're trying to get
love she is wearing a Grinch T-shirt she
is made after my own heart can we go in
there you don't want to go in there I love
this the little girls go and get the cheese
oh my God amazing you just walk around and eat
cheese all day a look at that poor little guy
nobody picked him go pick him why don't
you go up there go take a bite of his
cheese young lady right now starting with
the one who gave you permission to say no
yeah I'm Margo hello Margo
I am ni it's like a little
grou thank you thank you I am
a great mother did you see that
girls I oh they're gone they're in
there drinking with those cowboys
look a unicorn horn it's real all right came
from the Crooked Forest where unicorns still
live you crazy French freaks oh my god oh boy
oh I saw one once did you it
did it smell like candy was
it I thought I was is going to
die that he said he said the L
yeah it's so fluffy I want to
die they say if I made in pure
of heart goes into the Crooked Forest
the Unicorn will come and be hers wow
AG oh my goodness excuse me girls don't worry
I'm here are you okay unicorns are really real
I'm going to fight one I love her so much
I hope this unicorn is actually real me
too this is the adventure I want to go on
is them trying to find a unicorn what are
you doing did you just steal candies
yes that's a lot of effort for two
lollipops the police what do we do
what we do come on oh he's kicking
the he's getting the spark all right
I'm down bringing out pigs no not the
pigs cops and
[Music] pigs whoa
uh-oh oh it's going to turn into a boat right
yeah yeah cool I thought you were going to pee
your pants I did you did I mean the movie's
cool cute and fun it's not like mesmerizing
or something [Music] yeah [Music] Pizza why does
it look like the Warner Brothers lot yeah it does
right saw side like I'm pretty sure I just saw
a Vin Diesel cameo in the background H really
yeah [Music]
oh oh my
God love how they're not perturbed At All by
whatever the hell these things are [Music]
right
this movie is so Random there so
many things happening yeah there's
three different story lines four oh the
minions are in Hollywood we got the brat
guy we got Lucy kg I forgot about
that guy he hadn't been around in a
minute a lovely amazing wait when I use the
bathroom my toilet paper always turns pink after
I use it oh or some kind of red yeah I feel like
I don't we don't need to really um discuss it it's
been like that for days oh yeah become grew again
how awesome would that be oh please come on oh I
hope this movie does something really strange and
has them fall in love just go for it be weird that
you still want the Ste there is something what
do you want to steal what we steal the largest
diamond in oh from yeah all right and then return
it I'm finally going to get to see a unicorn there
was a chance did you might not find one it might
not be good unicorn finding weather why are you
disappointing her beforehand maybe unicorns
don't exist exist explore that part of the
woods I made could find one if she was pure and
heart I'm pure and heart right yeah the purest the
purest if I have a daughter and she doesn't end
up like her yeah you cancel it throw it in trash
throw it out throw that daughter out absolutely
right in the trash either into the trash or the
recycling either one of them will do just send her
somewhere else oh my goodness this I love get that
[Laughter] back look at him
snapping their way through
is this their version of Westside Story with
minions oh my God they run this person
love it they run it because they are true
villains look at him looking at the camera oh my
goodness can't the minions have taking over but
[Music] banana gr what you
saw Gru there wait what oh
pdsd a see gr always loved them time to watch a
very special episode of evil brat to see exactly
what I'm going to do to stupid tensil Town God
how's this guy not gotten over his TV show from
20 years ago like come on buddy chew on [Music]
this he's shooting his super sticky self-inflating
gum oh [Music]
goodness now that's Entertainment come on
let's make it a reality I will be honest
that studio is pretty cool his style I like it
I know I don't like him I'm going to film it
and get rich look over there holy moly that
is gorgeous unicorns here we come they love
candy what's that for f that looks like a
Simpsons uh donut this is brat it may not
look like there's so many plots happening so
much going on also where is like Margo and Mom
and those kids are just like allowed to go out
solo apparently into the woods that's crazy to
me climb up to the cube and enter here and once
I'm inside find the diamond I think we can have
it Dad villain suits this will make us Unstoppable
oh I you w i call the black one I really feel like
they could have done a lot more with the Drew
character though yeah he's just kind of like
loud and annoying yeah he's not really I don't
really know him as a personality other they're
just like the same and kind of yeah hello Mother
Amaro I am Nico I present you with big to confirm
my my engagement to your daughter engagement oh
that's what eating the cheese meant and nobody
knew it it's not happening who was I kidding a
dumpling like me with a goddess like you I will
never forget you Marco oh I'm pretty sure I won't
forget you either planed not work you you refuse
my son's engagement big may you and your daughter
Die slow death and be buried with onions oh no
they're cursed you do not want to mess with me
do you understand me yes yes good I think we just
need to oh okay that seemed like too easy like
the payoff wasn't good enough yeah right like I'm
really starting to feel the movie's weaknesses
yeah it's F it's a fine movie so far it's fine
yeah it's fine I'm not like I'm mostly excited
for this plot point and the minions those are my
favorite my whole life has been building to
this moment [Applause] [Music] uh what just
a goat it's a unicorn love that I can't believe
it that is so adorable so cute and she's allowed
to bring it home still don't see why I can't go
with you now is not the time to mess with the
plant hey father saw that coming
help me oh my God he's making so much
[Music] noise oh boy come on camouflage
B please and close your eyes and cover
your mouth you should have stayed in the
boat like how this look like a
video game oh my God okay all
right follow
me oh no oh
uh-oh
you this guy is such a liability
it's going so wrong all
wrong
oh hey hey he slightly contributed
something are they doing a prison
break uh oh they can just go right
through oh are they creating a flying device oh
interesting
awesome wait what is thaty going to how what's he
going to do did he just left no what
about him why you still have one of
these wait what just happening I don't know this
guy just doesn't know how to be a villain we get
it but I'm like would he really be that
dumb that's exploding Bubblegum don't do
it oh boy look at it CLI it's beautiful oh
he did bring it to life oh all right you
sh up he's going to spot us gross
open your mouth oh God Intruders
Intruders freeze GR there's two of you
now and this will be twice as much fun
I like how you can recognize
him right away yeah it took
him like a0 five seconds to be like
gr give me back my D go get him Brad
pack
oh a lot of these semi uh the crass humor
jokes don't you stick yeah sticky okay
they're just going to happen to miss
a hey guys what oh we got the diamond and we're
going to take it do the AVL and get our jobs back
you'll never ever go behind my back every ever
again okay that was really convenient yeah it
was no way we can't give the diamond back I
have to oh no is he going to partner up with
Brady oh and become a True Villain at least I
had the job what have you accomplished it was
so great I'll tell you what nothing no wonder
Dad thought you were such a failure dude too
mean we are no longer brothers that's fine
with me we are enemies gr I found a unicorn
I like how they they still call him grw instead
of Dad yeah right that's not actually a unicorn
but he has one horn life is just like that
sometimes we're hoping for a unicorn and we
get a goat that goat is so adorable lucky
is the best goat in the whole world world
that's right Agnes you could learn something
from her attitude who I'll take this can you
get the rest of the suitcases come on girls
let's go let's get physical physical I want
to change of plans girls instead of going
home what we're going to Hollywood that
was a good twist oh yeah let's go Clive
we've got a giant robot waiting that was
really well done yeah I like that Lucy
brat he took the girls what no this time
it's Persona Drew go away I don't want
to t you but he needs your help now no
I'm sorry I'm so sorry grw oh look out
what is that oh what are the odds oh boy
yay go get him wow great design of those
clouds oh boy wow that looks very tangible that
looks real giant robot that does not that looks
that looks great yeah hello Hollywood not
technically Hollywood because you did arise
in Santa Monica but I guess he moves fast I
was wonder if that was Santa Monica per it
was good old Hollywood and Highland is
going up in bubbles oh no oh no what
in the world oh is that supposed
to that is so mean lights camera
bler oh oh this is not
good this is actually Hollywood all these
buildings are in the right place crazy look
I've got the girls you two go take care of
brat damn you're able to spot them all right
man what is does she oh okay show that you're a
good mom I love it when a plan comes together a
it's oh is that the voice of the Family Guy
guy no I think it's the South Park guy the
South Park guy yeah that guy Trey Parker I
just heard it right [Music] now okay that
was easy the design of that looks so like oh real
it actually looks real yeah Brad pack go get that
back oh incoming well [Music]
uh oh so
annoying I swear drewy you better save
the day get um there you go now he's
coming into His True Villain skills cuz
he's fighting for something bigger than
himself hang on girls I got you I'm oh
no oh my goodness oh God him good job
Lucy whoa look at what we have
here all right save your twin
brother oh my God you got to
climb fast oh boy hurry up
just cut them all cut them
all what's happening go we're going to get
out of there Drew uh-oh he's going to blow up
buddy that looks pretty cool though now it's
time to die any last words grw I got two words
for you dance fight here we go oh unlike K
we knew that we knew this was going to happen
you're love to me
yeah come on G all right come on
come on G let's get rid of this
guy what you're looking [Music] for
bitching die by bitching classical
Rocky talk or onions it's not there's
no way it's that easy oh what how are
these weapons not working against these
bubbles these poor [Laughter] minions Soul
where it says soul in the background like a
billboard oh like for that movie that Pixar
movie
It's Raining Men hallelujah it's
[Music] raining love you mom say hi to
gr for me go go to bed to sleep with
the minions you have a perfectly nice
mansion guys come on oh boy he has an
umbrella oh my God wait what is this
I think they go do villainy stuff I
thought we said no more villainy
somebody's got to keep the family
tradition alive right oh they all suits
too let's get him he's my brother we'll
give him a 5 minute headit start wow what
a weird battle to be embroiled into too
yeah fighting your twin brother my brother/
roommate I have to fight every single night
just every night he comes home to the
same house and they're like love you
brother and then he's like I'm off to
do villainy all right five minute Head
Start that sounds like a nightmare yeah I mean
this movie was fine I still thought it was fun
my favorite plot points are always the minions
and obviously Agnes trying to find the Unicorn
if we could have stayed with them I would have
really I would have loved it I mean it's not
like bad I just I there were times I was sitting
here just going like I don't know why oh is that
a put no it's a regular I don't know why it's not
it wasn't as like there was too many plot points
and at no point was there any emotions pulling
me into being like Oh it's so sweet besides Agnes
she's always the one who's so sweet and makes me
like oh that's like really sweet I really felt
something other than that I just sort of was like
yeah okay I'm watching a a thing like yeah no it
actually I agree it this was this definitely was
diminishing returns like it looks yeah like in
the beginning we kind of thought it might be good
yeah in the beginning I was like I don't know what
people are talking about this is like really fun
and we're setting up a villain right off the bat
and he wins and he causes G to lose his job and I
thought that they were setting up a lot of great
ways to continue forward but it it definitely felt
like whoa what's going on here oh know just uh all
right there's stuff on screen happening with them
whatever um yeah know it it was these are really
cool credits they are distracting me but they're
really cool they're cool it's like what they did
with the mins in the last one yes um it's just
whenever it feels like I'm watching a mid credit
scene it's not a mid credit scene it's just them
chasing each other it's just that running around
okay I'll try not to be distracted by it um yeah
but as it progressed I I still I just didn't
really connect with anything um me neither it it
it just kind of felt like like this the last movie
sequel felt like a a a proper progression for Gru
and where his journey would take him and this felt
like they were making [__] up to make a movie
you know I mean yeah like they're just like add
this plat Point add this plat point and at even
as we got to like where they're trying to go and
break into the into the the the purple guy's house
whatever I just felt like kind of numb watching it
like even those those parts about him being sticky
being camouflag is supposed to be funny they're
going together he's like I didn't feel anything I
was like I don't even find this really that funny
but maybe it's because I don't know we didn't
set up enough with Drew the brother we didn't
really get to know him that much we get that he
was like kind of the sweeter one and he he wants
to be a villain but um I don't know I don't know
like what it he's really annoying though yeah I
know it's too many it's way too much grw Drew
energy like because they're very similar that
I'm like oh God thank God we're cutting to a
minion scene or like thank goodness it's the
girls now um and I still felt like the the plot of
like Margot being thrown in there with eating the
cheese and and Lucy having to stick up to uh to
the kids to to the family to become like more of
her mom and a mom figure we didn't even really
still set that up it was like literally just a
line in the beginning of like I'm still getting
used to the mother daughter stuff and then just
cut to her being like go eat that cheese and then
they she saves them at the end and Agnes calls
her mom normally in that part in a movie that was
set up well with great Foundation when the little
girl rolls over and says I love you mom for the
first time you would probably feel something or
be like close to tears I didn't really feel much
cuz I was like we didn't do there was way too many
plot points it felt like everything sort of got
half measured out you know they there was the
plot line with Drew and grew which uh I I think
definitely needed a little bit more meat on it
than like I never felt like I guess grw needed a
brother and then it didn't even really lead to an
arc yeah it just was like he was just there yeah
like they they got to the point because the whole
thing with Drew being a wanting to be a villain
got introduced like a little bit past the Midway
Point uh but you know guo goes over there and he
wants to meet his brother and then he just now he
has a brother and that was about it yeah there was
a little bit of a conflict for like two minutes
when you know he's that would be disappointing
you but then the girls got kidnapped so that was
resolved and right away and they started working
together instantaneously and Drew is just kind
of loud and obnoxious and then uh the story with
like there's stuff about the stories that I don't
feel like the the theme of the movie was even that
clear I kind of just felt like stuff was happening
you know um where the first one about being a
father and realiz that's more important then the
second one was Finding Love yeah and and then this
one was like what exactly wasn't about it we don't
even know like all that stuff with Margo and and
the getting engaged just felt like sketch comedy
uh didn't really matter and it was it felt Half
Baked half half cooked and even Agnes with the
Unicorn bit was like what did it really amount
to uh it was just like a thing for them to do
yeah like another because they were like we don't
have enough to write a good enough movie that's
just about this and then they set it up with the
villain um to try to provide I guess a met meta
angle to it but I would forget about him I would
totally forget he's in this movie that's why when
I was like there's three plot points you're like
there's four and I still didn't go like oh right
I went uh and then you had to explain it because
I forgot about that guy yeah in the beginning I
thought he was going to be really likable and and
something I didn't like him he was uh he just was
he he kind of annoying too I didn't leave much
yeah he's a little Annoying I prefer watching
him over Drew yeah I I agree and he's um um
yeah I mean I like the one little twist where
he he was posing as Lucy but other than and like
the visuals were really great again but when the
story weaknesses really stand out and and you're
just not feeling much for it the visuals can only
do so much to make up for that when the visuals
are not like it's not like watching spiderverse or
something where they're just like it's so insanely
good that you know that it's that it's a voice of
its own uh that that's not the case here it it
felt yeah it it definitely felt like they were
I really felt like the sequel the last one even
though I didn't preferred over the first movie was
still a real natural way this felt like they were
just trying to cash in on some [__] that they
didn't really need to yeah it it felt like all the
higher ups got around and was like throw this in
and I want this and this and we here's your money
but do this oh here's a good script but nope we
should have this this and this and then they were
like here you go and they went yeah make that and
I'm like did nobody screen this prior to be like
what is an audience reaction going to be because
I feel like most people would be like it was okay
but they probably wouldn't walk away going it was
good but then again like I'm just thinking with
an animation you can literally cut scenes and draw
new stuff so like you know what I mean like I mean
it takes a long time to like R all that [__]
well that's true the thing is Despicable Me came
out in what 2010 if I'm not mistaken it's 2017
and people who if if you're if your only target
audience's kids you should I think a lot of times
you got to be factoring in uh the fact that people
will be growing up you know and yeah they're true
it's like seven years have passed growing up with
it yeah yeah and like even the little girls don't
feel like they grow just feels like they don't
they're always the same age there's this passage
of time clearly yeah from Gru to then guu meeting
Lucy then grew getting married and then they're
positioned in the job like there's clearly a
passage of time and it feels like exact days
yeah yeah they're the exact same age like they
don't seem like they grew up at all right and
I think that would have aided it as opposed to
just putting them in like a funny scenario really
dealing a little bit more with that side bringing
it back full circle to them having to be parents
in a way instead of this random brother element
that I did not think helped aided I didn't care I
would have rather seen more family stuff like them
becoming more of a family and how do we get past
her thing of like becoming a mom and like maybe
the minions teach them something because the Min
there was that one little clip of the minion being
like but Gru are dad right and he thinks back he
looks at the bubbles on the ground and we're like
what is that and was like they didn't even Circle
back to that like real really sweet Montage of
like he's a dad also to these minions but they
got upset cuz they're like you're a real vain and
you're not anymore whatever but they never even
really went back to that and I would have liked
to follow that cuz that kind of made me feel
something like that he's a dad to the minions he's
a dad to the girls and now he has his wife to to
bring into the picture but it it was just sort
of like no we got to do like spy action stuff
and I just didn't I don't know I didn't care
you're so right about that because when that
moment happened I thought I was thinking this
is really interesting yeah because the minions
you you kind of just lump them all together even
though there's ones like I don't know Kevin and
whatever Mel they all have some of them have names
but they don't have distinct personalities I don't
know who's going to get mad at me for saying that
but they really don't guys they all kind of blend
together right um and I thought oh they're really
G to make this one distinct like this one we're
going to get the most connected to yeah there was
actually going to be a true emotional connection
because he's going to be the one who is not for
what everyone else is for right now and he wants
to get back to gr and I thought they were really
going to do something with that so that you had
like that one minion you really connected to and
I completely forgot about it until you brought
it up right now and I don't even know that it was
the same cuz there's the thing and when he looks
down at the bubbles he didn't have the little
hairs on the side of his head he was just bald
I think and then it cuts to like the guy with the
side hair with fishing and then a different one
with different hair in the different part of the
Montage so it was like a display of like oh he's
been a father figure to all the Minions at some
point right and does stuff with them I guess fun
things but yeah we we never got back to it and
I'm like that's a story I would I would follow
along with him like having to raise his daughters
who should be getting older yeah you know yeah I
don't know I mean uh like I I there's I what we're
talking about is all the the great misp potential
and the things that were yeah that stood out as
weak yeah but but the actual experience you know
honestly if I was if we weren't I think if we
didn't have a camera pointer at us and we were
just like friends hanging out and watching we
were like yeah it was fine yeah it's fine we
wouldn't be like picking it apart that but this
is what we do here I guess when it's like we're
supposed to do we're supposed to we're supposed to
review it and and as going through it of what what
we thought was the weak points I'm like yeah these
are the weak points about it but the but the movie
itself is is just like no it's just a fine I I am
disappoint I got to admit though I am disappointed
because of the fact that you know it when it's
a first movie I I let that excuse slide way more
where you're just like it's a kids movie yeah
yeah it's a kids movie when it's the first one
but when you have like two like really good ones
prior yeah that makes it really disappointing and
I can't just chalk it up to it's a kids movie at
that point no it's like it was thrown together for
the sake of earning money but like I I just think
I think it's weird because I tend to really like a
lot of universal films and I I feel like they've
done a good job in making films throughout the
years and I don't feel like they do a lot of that
what we just saw here where it's like just thr it
together we have a name and a thing and a theme
park and people love minions that I'm like what
no all always only make really good stuff even if
you they started feeling like oh we sell the brand
yeah yeah whereas the the second one felt like an
I heard the second one actually got like a best
pitcher nomination so for the animated Department
oh that one's a well put together movie yeah and
this felt like kind of like it belongs on a
streaming service yeah it felt like a not not
released into a thing like if for you to watch
and maybe come and go as you're making dinner if
you're not that interested in yeah this felt like
a straight to streaming service kind of movie um
I give it five out of 10 five .5 maybe I'll meet
you right there we didn't rate any of the other
ones but we'll rate this one we'll rate we'll rate
this one I mean and also you guys got to let us
know if you want us to watch the Minions movies or
other stuff kind kind of did kill my buzz for it
yeah I know right we're I think we might have to
move on to a different type of genre of film for
a while unless you guys are like minions are the
best you have no idea how good the Minions movie
is there's going to be a comments that are like
minions are bust yeah oh my goodness minions are
be unsubscribed don't do that we love you too
much this channel is horror animated and action
movies it is lately horror animated action no
consistent genre no not at all not true okay
well we love you guys leave that like leave the
comment ring the bells do all the stuff if you're
not a patron become one and I think that's it
that's it we love you goodbye [Music] banana